[Music]
if you are looking for most aggressive
yet
trickiest reply to the french defense
then you came to the right place
because in today's fifth lecture of
attacking jazz gambit
i am going to demonstrate the amazing
french wing gambit
which you might want to consider as a
complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice
in this video i am not only going to
give you an overview of this gambit but
my main focus will be showing you the
most high profile tricks and traps
which frequently occurred in this line
once again just keep an eye on the
database which is situated just below me
so that you can see
how many people exactly
fall for the particular trick
okay let's get started
after e4 e6
now the mainline move here is d4
but as we are playing for the wing
gambit
we start with knight to f3
and after black's usual response
d5 we push on with e5
here black can delay the c5 and play
other moves
but in those cases white always get an
advantage
so by far as you can see from the
database
majority of the games continue with
c5
to whom we deliver the surprise package
before
so what's the big idea
well again black has two major choices
one is to capture the spawn and the
second is declining by playing knight to
c6
so let's see each right turn
first
let me demonstrate what is the idea when
black captured this pawn
here
okay you can play the move a3 but i
don't like the structure after the moon
d4
so my recommendation is that you
continue with d4
and when black continue with knight to
c6
we play in a true gambit style with a3
okay if black doesn't capture
then we will take on b4 and then
continue with c3
so in most of the cases black took the
spawn
and
once again we are not interested
in pawn grabbing but continue with
c3
which will reveal
what is white up to
as you can see now
what has this tremendous pawn structure
in the center
which not only gains space
but it also block majority of black
pieces
and the most important factor is
not only we can regain our pawn back but
by playing the move bishop to d3
white get tremendous attack on the king
side
which we are about to see
let's see our first trick so i'm picking
the most frequent choice by black here
so bishop to d7 is the highest played
move here
and after that
remember this golden move bishop to d3
again we are not in a hurry to capture
the a3
what we are doing is we are targeting
the king side
now i'm really surprised that a6 has
been played in more than 2000 games
which is in fact a big time mistake by
black
and
after white's next reply
black is almost busted
you want to see it
watch it buddy
knight to g5
what a move
and as you can see
at 6 g6 bishop e7
all the tries by the black
leads to a disaster
let me show you how so first move is at
6 which is played in more than 200 games
big blunder
and i hope you already see it
yup this lovely sacrifice
knight captures app7 bam
well black two major pcs are hanging so
black doesn't have any choice
he has to take this knight
but after that the task is very simple
first you give this queen check
and black poor king has only one space
to go
after that
yup the another dazzling move bishop
captures a3
and would you believe black finished
just within the 12th move of the game
okay so roll back
and let's find out apart from f6 if your
opponent continue with
g6 which looks very natural right you're
blocking every single attack
but see yourself
h4
we are trying to rip apart the black
king side
and against this the most frequent reply
is at six
but
this leads to again
the problematic territory yup
you guessed it
knight captures
app7 king takes f7
and now queen check
forcing black to go to g7 as if he goes
to the e7 then bishop captures a3
again leads to
mating territory
so that's not good
g7 is forced
and after that
yup you guessed it
bishop captures g7 another dazzling
sacrifice
ripping apart the whole king's side
and funny enough
black has no defensive resources here
for example if we continue with moves
like queen to e7 then we have bishop
capture c3
dislodging the queen
and apart from it if black can't play it
then the next move is very obvious queen
f7
creating a complete mating havoc
so as you can see if black continue its
most frequent choice namely
bishop d7 and a6
then the disaster is looming
very quickly in the opening stage
so by far the second most popular choice
is
knight g to e7
and after our trademark setup that is
bishop to d3
black has two knight maneuvering
the first move i want to consider is
knight to g6
looks obvious
you are defending your king side
but
again white king sets up a very tricky
platform
starting with
knight captures a3
well black really doesn't want to
capture this knight because after bishop
takes a3
all the dark squares has been controlled
by the wide
so the natural move here is
bishop to e7
and trying to castle on the king's side
well now the fun begins for the white
and i propose my home preparation from
here
and that start with
h4
so if allowed we will play the move h5
and dislodge the knight
so accordingly black has two choices
either to capture on h4 or to play h5
well knight captures h4
most frequently played move here
but i'm afraid that's a poison pawn guys
and the simple refutation goes as follow
knight captures h4
bishop captures h4
and now this lovely queen to g4
double attack
forcing black to give back the material
after bishop to e7 and queen captures
g7 black rook in the corner hangs
and when he save it
rook to f8
we have this nice winning move
knight to g4
so idea is very obvious
what really white wants to do is he
wants to play knight to d6
get this bishop so that his dark square
bishop can be close to f6 and then take
the rook on the f8
it's simple plan but even though black
can see that one is coming he can hardly
defend this position
for example a6 has been most frequent
choice
but after this
very simple
knight to d6 jack
if king to d7 then rook captures at 7 is
a very strong reply
so black always take this knight
but after pawn takes d6
black has
two way to lose the game
if he does not take on d6
then after bishop to at 6 he is going to
lose his rook
and even though if he takes this pawn
he is a complete goner because of our
familiar tactic
yup
i am sure you indeed spotted
bishop to a3
bye bye rook on the f8
okay let's look at the second obvious
choice namely
knight to f5
and against this i prepared a very
sneaky maneuver so first
what i propose is you take back your
pawn
and after black ready to castle with
bishop to e7
you just continue with knight to c2
so that knight is going to be
transferred on the king side
and most importantly
black cannot castle here
why what's the problem because that's
the most obvious move and more than 50
games goes into this direction
but after this
i'm sorry but black is
completely losing
do you really want to try by yourself
well take your time pause this video and
go ahead
i am showing you right now
the star movies
g4
now black really don't want to play
knight to f6 and then
get his king side completely shattered
after bishop captures at 6.
so once again the frequent choice is
knight to h4
but
this leads to our amazing tricky
territory
and that goes with this forcing
variation
knight captures h4 bishop captures h4
now you play g5
so the idea is very simple we want to
play queen to h5
and give a double hit
so black response is forced
he has to take this pawn
and after that
very nice move
queen to h5
again black response is forced he has to
play at 6 in order to defend both the
threat
and now you play another aggressive move
rook to g1
so the simple plan is i want to capture
this bishop and then deliver at seven
beat
so the black response is forced he has
to take this bishop
and after rook takes
now white has a different thread namely
queen captures at six
so that's why few games in the database
continue with
king to h8
pairing this thread
but here comes the ggs recommendation
and that is
very amazing but the sneaky
king move yup you heard it right
king to d2
and what's the big idea
well idea is to connect the rook so that
we are all set to sacrifice
on g7
you might say hang on but i can defend
it with rook to g8 right
well you can but you don't stop my
sacrifice that is
boom
now it doesn't matter however black
recaptures
the best move here is king takes g7 but
after rook to g1
black king obviously can't go to h8 so
king to f8
but this is where the surprise comes
rook captures g8
what a move
so at first sight it looks like hang on
you're sucking everything so how are you
going to check mate black
but see yourself
now you stop king to going on a f8
square with queen to h6
and believe me what has a very simple
plan
that is
he wants to involve his knight on the
king side
and even though it looks very slow
black cannot do anything about it
for example f5 so black is trying to
defend the seventh rank
obviously we are going to take it
and after queen to c7
we play knight to e3
see how pathetically black queen side
pieces has been played
as none of them are actually helping
the poor black king
let's see a sample line
b6
knight to g4
bishop to b7
queen to g6 jack and after king to f8
and the moon knight to at 6
the mate is inaudible and even though
black can throw some checks here
white can safely negotiate
and coming out on top
you